okay let's i'm i'm more in a middle game
move to start so
what i'm thinking of doing is you know
sort of i'll give you a warm-up problem
and then after that i'm thinking of
doing some work in the area that we were
doing last time sort of the
the intersection of tactical and
positional thinking giving you as much
practical advice as possible
on the general topics of you know
calculation positional reasoning without
just pounding
random calculation problems if you know
what i mean because i know that you
mentioned that you sort of do that kind
of stuff yourself how does that
generally sound
yeah i have been trying to two tactics
today
[Music]
let's start with a sort of a simple
simple study
uh very very simple just to get kind of
get your confidence back up i think
you'll get this one quickly
um this is the ending of a of a
relatively famous study
um but it's uh just a couple couple move
combinations so
pasting it in right now oh
oh oh it's i think it's simpler than you
think just to get it okay
okay like i'm just like how how simple
no no i won't give you one of those like
provoca studies that's like 15 moves
from style no actually like i think
actually symbol but take us again
same rules if i take as long as you need
i'm never going to rush you
and you know my chat you can always get
involved as well in the comments so
white to play and win here
uh okay why didn't i win here
this looks this looks like an end game i
would potentially play
yup yeah this is a very real i think the
best studies come from realistic uh
realistic games
um
okay so bishop
to d2 well so you're threatening so i
have two moves to stop
you threatening checkmate on a8 if i go
b4 trying to vacate
some squares for my king right i can go
here and then take your
bingo and that leaves me with only one
move which is of course to take that
bishop with check
yeah and it got casey very nice rookie
and there's themes like this all around
rook end games where you're attacking
the rook and you're threatening
checkmate so
i can go here but that only staves off
track mate very nice pretty cool
bishop d2 only winning move we should
also point out rook and bishop against
rook in most cases is a draw so
it's not like i can do anything here and
win the right
yeah um so let's jump right into we'll
start on the sort of positional end of
things i'll give you a couple of
positions through the lens of which
hopefully we can talk a little bit about
positional reasoning how to incorporate
incorporate calculation into your
general thinking without relying
exclusively on your calculation
and hopefully i can sort of fill you up
with as much advice
as as possible but as usual you'll stop
me if i'm going too fast or too slow
talking too much
that's probably going to happen so don't
worry
let me paste in the next position this
is going to again be
i think relatively simple this is um
from an old game an old russian game
uh from mikhail botvenic who hopefully
most of the uh
chad members are familiar with of course
one chat
you guys are all like 2 500 right right
right kyle my savage
world champion from from the soviet
union
one of the strongest players of the
first and even the second half of the
20th century
and uh one of bobby nick's early games
featured this position that you see in
front of you
and well of course it's if it was black
to move i would not be giving this to
you
uh but maybe be giving this to charlie
but it was uh
white
he will never forgive me for that diss
never just don't
completely between us chat i didn't
listen uh
so of course three obvious candidate
moves can you name them
um c takes c5 e takes g5 and
knight takes i think you're ready to
take on gary caspar so
the question is which of these moves do
you play and
and why and you can be as conceptual or
as concrete as you want
wait this is sorry is this was this
tactical i think i just like
missed it's more positional so we're
starting more on the positional end of
things that doesn't mean there's no
tactics and
or no calculation but i'm gonna start on
the positional end of the thing we're
gonna move slowly toward
the tactical realm sort of that's how i
planned it thanks jared mighty for the
sub
for the prime time all right
let me figure this out okay
so
[Music]
i have played these kinds of positions
before
i think i remember if i was playing for
a draw i would take back with the c
pawn because of the pawn structure
symmetrical
um and that usually leads to pretty
equal end games but if i take back with
the e pawn it gives me a little bit more
playing chance because the
e7 pawn on black side is going to be a
little bit weak
come in the future
so far
other moves aside
okay yeah that's my that's like the
reason you know what i think about the
moves but
so ed would be your choice here yeah
probably
probably and you would be absolutely
right this is i think simpler than it
looks so it's very important to
understand
um don't necessarily shy away from
unbalanced pawn structures and the key
here is to realize like you pointed out
the c7 pawn is what's going to kill
black in the long run
what would be white's plan in in a
situation like this
white's long-term plan given you know
the weakness that you just pointed out
yeah i mean very simply paid to like
double up the rooks
exactly exactly double up the rooks on
the e file attack the target so
sometimes against stronger players there
can be this temptation as you point out
to go for the symmetrical construction
but this is actually worse for white
and it might seem like white is more
space but the reality is this bishop on
g2 is clogged by white's own pawns
um and and black is the one who has
immediate control over the c
file so something to the effect of
taking everything and even queen b6 can
be very very unpleasant for white
um so i largely think space advantages
can be overrated as we see in the nimzo
yeah that is true and here white is
white is struggling because of this
bishop and because this rook is going to
come to ca the other rook is uh
pressuring a2 so e takes d5 is the key
to the position
so the key here not to be afraid of
unbalanced bond structures
and identifying potential targets that
you can uh that you can pressure that's
sort of one of the best types of
positions to strive for
and i take c6 here i should just point
out very quickly
is it looks cool but
this is a little bit inferior it gives
him a
gives black a very good center yeah i
mean even cd
this is just too many trades have
happened there's a lot of air going on
here black can try to put his queen on
b6 so no need to give black
any extra advantages that is true
um okay very very good now let's get to
some some more fun stuff the next
position i'm going to show you made
actually a very big impression on me
okay and the concept that
i want to talk about through its prism
is what i call inaccessibility and i'm
going to talk about what that is of
course
um and i'll let you try to solve the
position all right
as soon as my computer unfreezes okay
there we go
copy position i think i've i'm hyping
this up and you're going to be like what
is this
crap okay so this is a game between
two grand masters sergey and tomaszewski
uh from a couple of years back very very
strong players both in the 2700s
oh all right and don't be intimidated by
that though i think you can find the
move so it's white to move and the way
that i suggest you approach this
is prophylactically first asking
yourself what is black's
intention how does black intend to to
develop active play in this position
then of course you try to find ways to
stop that
but you'll see that there is a catch so
i'll i'll shut up and let you think
about it
okay so it's black's point of view it's
white it's white to move oh white okay
yeah yeah yeah white sorry i wasn't
clear on that white to move
okay um
i mean the first thing you think about
in these positions is the palm breaks
right so b5
or e4 those are the automatic first
thoughts um
[Music]
oh
another sort of idea i might have
actually no so right now i have like a
dark squared bishop and all of my
opponent's pawns are on the white
light square interesting observation um
so something
hikaru wants to know if i like french
fries with mayo
no i don't i like french fries with
ketchup i personally hate mayonnaise
actually
really can't stand it i only like it if
it's in like the junior mcchicken at
mcdonald's
if there's mayonnaise in anything i'm
throwing that sandwich out unfortunately
i'm just
it's one of those things for me
oh but um yeah five people in my chat
are greens thank you guys
how do you like how do you like your
steak uh medium well i used to actually
get well done but
i've as i got older i know
oh wait you're on the same page okay
great finally met someone who's similar
because oh my god
it changed when i was i was at my mom's
birthday party this is a couple years
ago we went to you know like a nice
italian restaurant and i got steak and
the
i will never forget the look that i got
from the waiter when i said well then it
was a look of
pure and unadulterated hatred
um you know i was not worth the the
chair that i was sitting on or the paper
that i was printed on so from that point
on i've started getting medium well
but i'm a well done person at heart all
right awesome
hell yeah this is this is against
everybody in chat
yeah okay you snot steak snubs you're
still welcome in the stream so
in any case so so i would actually
approach this
also remember from the perspective of
black's ideas as well what is black
threatening here
and and threatening i'll put in quotes
there's no like black's not attacking
any pieces here and that's what makes
this a little bit harder than usual
but it still is a positional threat that
black has
i think e5 very good very yeah
definitely black's idea here
definitely that was that's why i was
gonna say do i want to push f4 which
locks my bishop in and leaves all of my
opponent's pawns on the light squares
or do i just let him push e5 that's the
right question to ask
so in this situation you would want to
weigh the pros and the long-term pros
and cons of playing f4 so what else does
f4
weaken let's play this on the board for
a second because it does look kind of
absurd from the perspective of squares
i do think that it gives black to
opportunity to play like g5 and stuff
but um and just because the center is so
close like you can get away with it
what about that e4 square what if he
ever gets a knight on e4 do you can you
imagine how much of a nightmare that's
going to be if you get tonight yeah
dude i don't even have a light squared
piece and i can't even like swap out
that night is gonna be disastrous if he
slips the knight into e4 you're gonna
regret the day you were born so is it
worth
then given all these cons
the pro of f4 is obvious that it stops
e5 what would be white's plan in this
position
um
okay so
i would
being going for like b5 i guess opening
up the
queen side very good and
so when you look at this intuitively and
and you can take as long as you do you
think that it's
i'll retract this move to let you think
from the starting position is it worth
flying f4 is the key question that you
have to ask yourself here
are the positives worth the negatives
honestly if my opponent just pushes e5
and i don't do anything the worst thing
that he can play is
e4 because i don't care if he takes on
d4
okay but if he pushes e4 um that might
be a
little bit annoying um just because i
don't think i'm gonna
take back since he'll take back with the
rook
once again just getting that outpost for
himself good and then that e3 pawn
is gonna be a weakness that black can in
fact access right so i was just thinking
if i retreat my queen and you place e
takes f3 i play g takes f3
it's not quite an endgame but i also
feel like my kings
i don't know like i'm very okay with
leaving my king kind of unsafe so i
never know if i have the best judgment
for this
um but yeah i guess if it came down to a
game that i would be playing over the
board i'd be playing
b5 here immediately so very very
interesting in reality the game
continuation was f4 oh
and and let's unpack this for a second
so normally
in my experience analyzing games and
looking at you know alpha zero and
recent developments in chess computing
it appears to me that humans and it's
not just you it's everybody
we tend to underestimate the danger
of having an unsafe king we tend to
underestimate king's safety as a concept
so this has actually changed my approach
to the game somewhat i feel like
any sort of deficiency in king safety um
is a lot more thank you
thank you nepo for the raid appreciate
it um
well now he's going to be watching this
what kind of what kind of crap are you
talking about
but basically i've never realized to
what degree
king safety is a crucial concept
and even the slightest efficiency in
king safety can be punished mercilessly
so let's unpack
how that actually works in practice i'm
going to try to convince you
that it is worth stopping e5 now i'm
going to take on b5 here so as not to
give up the pawn
and i'm going to go e5 and there's two
problems that i want you to notice here
first of all i want you to understand
that
it's going to be a while before white
actually gets stuff done
on the queen side he's gonna have to
play rook b1 then eventually go rook b6
and it's going to take a while he might
have to bring the other rook around to
a6 right
so it's a couple of moves black on the
other hand e4 comes very very fast so
which move here
would you play um what move were you
sort of processing beforehand
i was just looking at queen d2 okay now
i'm gonna take
all right now i'm gonna go knight g5 and
i'm gonna show you how quickly things
start melting down here for white
uh oh
right so i'm gonna think about ways that
i can involve my queen in the attack one
maneuver that immediately comes to my
mind
um and i'm not looking at the exactly or
maybe queen f7 either one
yeah maybe queen g6 i don't think it
really matters i was thinking about this
but i was like uh
i could like maybe get away with it
right and now what i'm gonna do
is i'm going to let you take on g5 and
claim that and then you're going to be
left with a very weak pawn on e3 oh you
want to do this
yes i wasn't going to take all right
let's add some tabasco sauce here
to the pizza oh no oh yeah
no tabasco sauce that's not good i feel
like i get the point
yeah yeah so this just would you agree
with me that this is at least a little
bit unpleasant
yeah definitely and you can see how it's
hard from a distance to realize that all
these problems kind of creep
up on your king it's not only the king's
safety king safety is also a
jumping off point because by solving
your king problem
you're introducing other weaknesses into
your position so right as a piece
general piece of advice
try to almost err on the side of caution
when it comes to king's safety
now let's talk about f4 for a second it
has two principal defects thank you
all around for the sub first of all the
weakening of the e4 square second of all
the
obvious blunting of the bishop but
both of these are either irrelevant
or entirely short-term problems so in
terms of the e4 square
and i'll do the counting for you black
needs a staggering
eight moves to get his knight from f7 to
e4
e and let me draw this knight h8
knight g6 97 then he's got to move the
king he's got to go knight ga move the
queen
knight f6 at 94. eight moves and chess
is in it so the earth is going to turn
into a supernova
by the time that knight gets to e4
um that'll be pretty intense so that's
what i call inaccessibility
you know that famous paradox of like a
tree falling into the
in the forest and and the question is
does the tree make a sound if nobody
hears it so i treat weak squares the
same way a lot of people look at a weak
square oh my god i upload
look at the square on e4 it's a
nightmare but a square is not weak if
it's inaccessible to your opponent's
pieces so don't be afraid to weaken a
square
if you have determined that your
opponent cannot get a piece onto that
square in a timely fashion
okay um carlos silva says you can do it
in seven oh my goodness and um
essentially um i think we get the point
though
yeah yeah i think the points
yeah so now let's get to the bishop um
this bishop can actually activate itself
uh
via a certain mechanism how
can you find a way for this bishop to
reach some sort of life potentially in
the future
e1a5 c7 exactly right that's exactly
what happens later on in the game white
can attack at his leisure black has no
counter play g5 can be
simply ignored um with b5
and g takes f5 only introduces further
weaknesses in black's position such as
the e6 pawn
and i'm not going to show you the rest
of the game i think you get the point as
you mentioned but
white ended up winning this game oh i
ended up winning this game
and i respect that that's sort of the
general
uh thrust of the insight i wanted to
make about weak squares and in
accessibility
and you know and realizing that it is
okay to make positional concessions
um it chess is a game of concessions a
game of tit for that tit for tat you
cannot get everything all the time
for sure let's practice this with a more
classical game between bobby fischer and
wolfgang unsicker in the night in 1970
actually very very similar concept
um slightly different move but very
similar concept following position arose
out of the opening
and here bobby fischer with the white
pieces applied the
very same concept doing the very same
thing uh
in order to make a great deal of
positional gain he did weaken
particular square so think about this
tell me what comes to mind
wait it's uh white to move mm-hmm
yeah i feel like i just kind of play
moves when i play blitz and i don't
really think enough
so
we're really exaggerating the process of
thinking but that's also how you learn
you get better at
subconscious decision making when you
practice conscious decision making
yeah no but i've been joking today i
just shut off my brain
like i was literally just auto auto
moving
all good
um yeah okay let's see
you're trying to bait him somehow
um
okay well i'm guessing
black slide squared bishop is going to
struggle a little bit with developing
because my knight's looking nice on d4
and also
his king is still on this the the
diagonal over here so
very good good observation so far look
at this light squirt bishop and it's
really only one prospect of developing
which is maybe something like this
um so maybe if you can close that bishop
in somehow
yeah i was just thinking about playing
h3 but then then i was also thinking
like does it even matter if he plays it
because i have like queen b3 check and
then queen takes b7
yeah that's true that's true um but the
way you can also think about it is this
bishop if it's going to be a long-term
problem
what can you tell me about this bishop
on d6
um it's going to be the better bishop
yeah it's the it's the better so imagine
a scenario where you've traded the dark
squared bishop and left
white black with only the light squared
bishop that will be
a game changer right i mean that'll be
that'll revolutionize the whole position
for white
right so then the question becomes can
you try to orchestrate
the trade of the dark square bishops
here
um what kind of plan can you come up
with to trade those bishops
well definitely f5 and bishop f4 is the
simplest
but what drawback does this have though
right like how can you weaken a square
like this and yet fischer plays f5
um and if it was anybody other than
fischer i'd probably look at this move
and laugh at it
but let's unpack bishop e5 for a second
the reality is just by putting a piece
on this square
it doesn't necessarily mean anything and
white simply chases the bishop way so
for example here
white isn't even really in a hurry but
what i can do is give a check on b3
and then he could go rkd1 but he could
basically go knight f3
chasing the bishop away and then he
could maneuver this knight onto what
square in order to permanently either
chase the bishop away from d6 or trade
it
one sec i'm gonna close my window
there's a very loud party going on in
the pool
and july 5th yup exactly hangover party
all right we're good i mean we can try
rick d1 and says his pin just
just exchanged the bishop off that way
but good idea as well
but specifically how about with the
knight specifically
knight d2 knight c4 exactly what i had
in mind and that also opens up the
possibility of bishop f4
so you see how just weakening a square
alone does not necessarily guarantee
your opponent a good position
um and so is this making sense so far
yes it is
and queen e7 was played in the game so
how does fischer follow this up
um we are still on a mission to exchange
off that bishop
so bishop f4 bingo bishop f4 trading off
the bishops
that's exactly what happened and black
still had control over e5 but eventually
what fisher did was
he brought his knight to f3 he placed
his rook on e1 and he broke through with
e5 and black was left with his dud of a
bishop
this runt of a bishop and eventually
fischer just choked him out of air
okay um i respect that so so the spirit
that i sort of
you know advise you to encompass is one
of
always being concrete and not letting
positional preconceptions dictate
the way that you play your immediate
intentions in a position
always have to transcend sort of general
positional principles about weakening
squares or doubling pawns or whatnot
so you know be a rebel on the chessboard
is is i guess uh a very shorthand way of
saying that
uh so how does that generally sound to
you yeah
i mean i i definitely think that these
are the kind of positional games where
it's like
like if i start start thinking about it
deeper i can definitely start
understanding them but it's not really
something i'm able to do in like a short
period of time
right no but that's but that's okay and
by looking at these positions
carefully in in a practice session you
start to
it's not the position specifically that
that help you improve it's the thought
processes that you put in place
if you think like that a couple times
and and this isn't something that you
recognize necessarily but before you
know it
you start applying those correct thought
processes in blitz games i think that's
how improvement generally works
it's not something that goes on at the
very surface for sure for sure so
let's proceed let's start to move a
little bit closer to
the realm of sort of specific tactical
thinking maybe this will be a little bit
more fun for you
but no i mean positional puzzles but i
think it's something that
like me and a lot of other people just
sort of disregard
you know just sort of what like
disregard yeah and
what i want to make very clear to the
chat and people who are like uh glad
eyes
blazer daniel's talking about this
dispositional i don't need to know that
i'm too weak for that
i don't think anybody's too weak for
these concepts i try to illustrate them
clearly and i think
people can apply them at their own level
um you know
be bold even if you're 1500 it's not
like you're not allowed to apply
positional
i don't buy into that whole school of
thought of oh positional chess can only
be started when you're at a certain
rating i don't believe that
i believe anyone can really come to
understand these concepts if they're
well taught
whether or not they're well taught well
that's that's not for me to decide
that's for you guys to tell me
um i'm sure they could be taught better
but i but i'm doing my best to lay them
out
you know in comprehensible terms this is
good stuff
thank you so let's move on to this is an
obscure game
uh between the two relatively unfamiliar
players black was a grand master from
yugoslavia
uh this is a game from the 1960s now
flip this so that you're facing black
all right um and it is black to move
here
i'm not going to introduce this in any
way but what i want you to do is try to
make
as many observations as possible and
then maybe that'll lead you to
the correct move this position shows you
how you can marry positional thinking
and specific calculation in the best
possible way
i'm guessing black's supposed to be
winning this
black's supposed to be putting pressure
yeah
okay um
okay well i mean all the pawns on the
dark squares which is horrible for
white's bishop
because it's a dark square bishop um
it's
pretty pog for us oh thank you so much
curly queen for the raid thank you
um i do think it's pretty okay for us
because
even though it's also blocking our
bishop it's more white cannot take his
own pawns
yeah so we got a nice bishop that can do
something uh-huh
yeah okay
we also have like the one open file
multi we have the a phone
yep on which our queen is parked yeah
and aside from that our knight
also has the potential to go to um
e4 even though you just do that so i
don't really know if like this is not
really a thought but it's it exists
did i introduce you to the three move
role i don't think
last time if it's not done in three
moves it doesn't exist
so how many moves is knight f87 that's
four
yeah okay so that's a great question i
mean i wouldn't be
dismissive of it in principle but in a
position like this
which has quite a few pieces and it's
not like white is frozen in space
i would put that on the back burner i
mean at least i would start by looking
at more immediate ideas
right for sure but good application
there i'm glad you are you remember that
and retained it means a lot to me
um okay so something else we can think
about is maybe breaking through
on the king's side um i mean obviously
it's like a queen and minor piece end
game so sacrificing
for this doesn't really make sense
unless there were less unless the queens
got swapped off and
maybe if the bishops got swapped off too
right so i see a lot of people in chat
suggesting sax on f4 and h4 that's a
classic application of
almost tactical brainwashing i do that
too where you assume that
any position that you're given the
solution has to be very tactical yeah
but in real life it's not always like
that there are some very subtle
maneuvers that are sometimes the
solution
this is just one of those positions yeah
um i do think that at the end of the day
this pawn is
probably gonna be quite weak um if i do
something like
bishop f6 it's not gonna be able to
attack it directly which i'm most
annoyed by yup good but are there any
weak
other weaknesses maybe that you can try
to attack there's the king which is like
chilling on day two we can maybe like
put queen a2 or something like that
incorporate that into whatever
combination you did you choose yeah
good and other weaknesses um
there is one other pawn that definitely
is weak by our definition
yeah okay i mean this is
within the three move rule okay so what
can you tell me about the move knight c7
here looks a little bit awkward um kind
of like me at prom but
what you know yeah
you go for it so knight c7 you're
threatening knight a6 and if you play
knight a6
the pawn on b4 is indefensible so
actually believe it or not white has
only one way
to defend that pawn to lend
reinforcement to that pawn
wow and and what would that be
um
wait a minute knight c2 knight c193 very
good
so let's play these moves on the board
knight c1 knight a6 knight d3 but now we
see the tension has arisen
over this pawn on b4 so knight a6
knight d3 black to move oh and then
there's just knight takes before
exactly so this is where the tactical
component comes in
you never switch off your tactical
detector even when
you're looking for positional solution i
don't know if you're playing the moves
in my street yeah you can go ahead and
play knight takes before okay
yeah just to show the crowd so if queen
takes before then the queen is pinned so
obviously i have to take this way
and that's it the floodgates i mean it's
not just a pawn that's one it's the
whole position that now collapses for
example let's say i go king e2
yeah you really just don't want all your
pawns in the darkness
yeah this is the worst this is what
kills white at the end of the day so how
does black actually
finish this off um i don't think
uh i don't think it's right to exchange
the queens
so yeah not yet yep exactly bishop a3 is
the best move
very simple exactly and notice that the
king
so queen e3 for example trying to get
the king t the queen to e8 what would be
the sort of best way of disarming this
now i'll give you a yep exactly then the
queen could come out to e4
yeah and because the pawn's already on
b4
you the queen trait is warranted because
b3 comes very very fast
so this is sort of the marriage of
tactical and positional thinking we
identify all the weaknesses we come up
with a positional idea
after our opponent defends against this
idea we switch gears
and we start looking for a tactical
solution at the end
um okay so let me
paste in the next position give me a
moment all right
and this one is
again um it's going to be sort of a
middle ground between
positional reasoning and tactics where
there's there's components of it the
specific components of the position you
have to take into account but
it also has a positional flavor to it
and uh these are quite a bit more boring
than the positions you find them let's
say puzzle russian i'm doing that
deliberately
because i believe that this is real
training these are actual positions that
arise on the board
yeah yeah i think i think this will be
good for us i've had a terrible terrible
puzzle rush day
for every tactic i did wrong i had to
eat a dose of wasabi
oh gosh man that does not sound very fun
thanks dragon for the sub
so um this is a position that happened
between two two twenty six hundred gems
jorge meyer uh someone that's familiar
to most viewers it was white
okay and it is why to move again it's a
situation where there's three feasible
candidate moves you can take on b5
with two different pieces or you can
take the queen on d8
and it's a question of well how the heck
do you approach a situation like this
how do you decide
which piece to capture with um and
take your time because there is a
correct solution here it's not one of
those
kind of like oh all three are good um
there definitely is a correct solution
here so as long as you need
all right i just want to let my chat
know that i have turned them off so i
will not be reading chat
absolute focus i like it i have to uh
take a leak so i'll be back in about a
minute that's okay all right
all right i'll be right back chet okay
um like i said i don't have my chat open
but i'm here thinking
all right so bishop's attacking my queen
and my rook
if i take his queen he can he has to
basically take my queen
um so rip takes bishop takes a4
if i take on a8 or kicks a8 then i have
knight takes a4
after which where we will have equal
material
do we like that though do we want more i
feel like we always want more
okay i mean i'm down a whole minor piece
in this position so
if i take here i'm gonna be still
attacking the queen i'm also gonna be
attacking the bishop
so queen takes b5 queen c7
maybe
and then i have rook d5
but then there's bishop to d6
wait a second oh
okay queen takes me five we see seven
knight takes 95 and the queen just moves
away
okay queen takes b5 c7
i feel like it has to be this i really
really do
all right i am back welcome back
um yeah i was just saying that i don't
think it's going to be rook takes d8
because after it takes d8 bish takes a4
rick takes a8 rook takes a 9 takes a4
we have the same amount of material
right and i feel like white wants
something more
yeah and the bishop can just come back
there so it's really not um
it's nothing nothing to write home about
exactly right so we're down to basically
two
okay uh so now we're down to queen takes
before so first of all i
looked at 95 very very very briefly but
i just feel like after queen b6
um there is not much going
on in that position right
that's also a good point so what can you
say about queen takes b5
well queen x85 queen c7 is like your
your
only move kind of well there's a there's
sort of another
possibility oh there's like oh queen b6
right so two possibilities queen c7 and
queen b6
okay um i actually did not think about
queen b6
all right well maybe with queen b6 i can
just play
rook to d5
and you're attacking the two loose
pieces of black hats yes and what about
queen c7
um i was also thinking about rook d5 but
there's bishop d6 now
exactly so this speaks to the importance
of being very very flexible you see one
idea against one move
but you don't get attached to it and you
kind of reevaluate the position with a
fresh pair of eyes so
if you forget about rook d5 for a second
there's a much more natural
negative spies a humongous initiative
because after queen c6 what is the most
accurate way of liquidating bingo knight
c7 when's the exchange
so it might appear that this is nothing
to write home about but i think this
problem really emphasizes well the sort
of art of logical thinking
you use calculation here to rule out
knight takes b5 and rook takes d8 and
then you use sort of flexibility
and ideation i guess to come up with
responses to queen c7 and queen b6 so
this happened in the game
rook t5 and it's a very cool position
you're attacking these two pieces
how is bishop d6 here met um
with wait a minute
just rook takes e5 yeah simply rook
takes c5
and uh you win two pieces for a rook and
white is completely winning
and in the game i think black took here
uh the surprisingly the move knight
takes b5 ensued
no surprising mind-blowing mind-blowing
who would have guessed i know it's
impossible to to realize that would have
been that would have followed bishop d6
and now simply knight takes d66 and rook
takes d66
um is very good for white and it's very
important to also realize this bishop on
h6
always a huge asset in the end game
because it's cutting off the king and
it's already creating a precedent
potentially for
various types of mating nets and stuff
like that
[Music]
so if knight c4 for example what would
be
it might appear that black is picking
off the pawn on e4 what would be white's
most sort of clinical response here
um rook d4
yeah exactly what's the idea after
knight takes b2
just play rick b1 and just go for the b7
pawn yeah
oh wait the knight's also just trapped
yeah the knight is trapped and you can
also go bishop z1 here that's actually
the most accurate to trap the knights oh
okay okay so i notice how like you're
never stopping the search for tactics
for concrete solutions to the position
you're always looking for stuff is the
night trap
you know because risky one doesn't work
of rook d8
bingo so rook v1 is less accurate
there's rook actually rookie theater
rook 88
and the game goes on white is still much
better here after rook before rook takes
b7 but
black has saved his knight a knight
isn't a knight
right exactly and that speaks to the
fact that every single position doesn't
matter how much of an innocuous end game
it might look like
features these tricks you know chess is
full of these little tactical tricks
that you have to be aware of
at every single moment in the game you
can never stop the search for them
got it so there's one more concept that
i wanted to talk about through the lens
of one more
game this is a game um and i have to
preface this because it is
a game of john nepam nishis but it is
one that he lost
i swear i swear that i planned this
beforehand
i this is no way any kind of diss i
greatly appreciate the raid and uh jan
is a player that i respect
to the utmost degree so it has nothing
to do with any of that i think it's just
an instructive
objectively an instructive game um
and i'm sure it is one that yon you know
probably forgotten a long time ago
because this the year of this game was
2012.
this was basically eight years ago this
was exactly eight years ago
and it speaks to a concept that i call
the wish list
um and i'll talk about what that concept
entails in a moment when i paste the
position
so nepo was uh was white and a russian
grand master by the name of uh
dimitri ferdanov was uh was black
and we actually joined the battle here
in an opening uh
it's been a slav defense and um
this is one of the more interesting
slobs i've seen yeah it got pretty
interesting it got pretty unbalanced and
black took on c4 and played e5
so black to move here obviously because
the bishop is hanging
and let me introduce to you the concepts
first and then i'll let you think about
the position so
the concept of a wish list is basically
what i think players don't do enough of
is when a critical moment
arises in the game what i mean by that
is you have a certain decision to be
made
and clearly the impact of this decision
is quite significant as it is here you
have to decide where you're putting the
bishop
um you have to keep in mind you know
like you're making a wish list for
christmas or whatever you're like i
wanna
i want a new tesla i want a house i'm in
the best part of the town
i want this and this and this and most
likely you're not gonna achieve
you know even one percent but even if
you achieve like half a percent of your
wish list
if you're thinking big it's sort of more
lucrative more beneficial to
have lofty ambitions than to have you
know
uh to have low ambitions and it's the
same thing in chess when you're looking
at a position you have to try to figure
out
what you want to achieve in an ideal
scenario imagine that
everything goes according to how you
want it to go you can manipulate the
game
artificially to trade the pieces that
you want to trade
remove the pieces that you want to
remove etc etc etc
if you actually do the work of asking
yourself
what the ideal scenario is oftentimes
you will find the hidden resources in
the position
that allow you to actually accomplish
those goals and turn them into reality
whereas if you don't do that
you won't even be looking for creative
solutions to these problems
so try to apply this here with black to
move you don't have to do that exactly
in that fashion
um but i think that is the best way to
arrive at the solution
so we just we just do what we want to do
mm-hmm
uh okay well i mean what annoys you
about this like
every type of question that you can ask
yourself you should go ahead and ask
yourself
well yeah i mean my bishop is just flat
out being attacked um
positions feeling very uncomfortable not
gonna lie
like i it's just the knight is already
on f5 the bishop is on
c4 it's just even my king this feels
like a spanish gone really really wrong
exactly good good observation so far
um yeah and my light square bishop is
unable to be developed within the next
two moves because
knight sitting here um so if i would
play something like
you know bishop to f4 would probably
make a lot of sense because i have less
space
so i just want to get rid of some of my
material so you want to you want to
orchestrate some trades here in order to
lessen the load so to speak
but yeah again let's let's think about
this from an ideal perspective what
piece would you
really like to remove from the word what
is annoying you the most
my opponents or mine your opponents uh
not on f5 definitely the knight on f5
right that's that's sort of if you get
rid of that knight at least
your load is slightly less and you're
not as imminently in danger in terms of
your king safety
um so you should actually keep that in
mind because
when you come up with an ambition like
that you should at least spend a little
bit of time trying to figure out
maybe there is a way that i can remove
that knight by force
because if you move your bishop let's
say to f8 what happens then well white
has a chance to apply further pressure
on your position
by means of bishop g5 and here things
get really hairy
right um so let's go back to this
position
and here you can think in that type of
way
okay um so if i'm trying to remove the
knife my bishop is still under attack
right so obviously got to do things in
sequence to take care of the bishop
maybe you can take care of the bishop in
a certain
way
i mean then the bishop would also look
pretty good on e5
yeah so bishop b5 is is probably the
second best move behind sort of the top
move
but what are you sort of what is your
next move going to be in a position like
this
um knight b6 and bishop takes
f5 now maybe you could do that all in
one fell swoop though
oh because if i play knight b6 and
knight takes d6
i've got that loses because the knight
on d6 then simultaneously
yeah i was going to say that it will
look great but you can do something with
your bishop of a
forcing nature oh there's bishop h2 and
then there's
an outlandish looking move but if you
play bishop h2 let's go along with this
for a second
king h1 black to move okay now i do
actually have uh i mean that's even
knight e5
too but right knight b6 is sort of less
and some people in the chat were
suggesting 95 but remember as my coach
would tell me you're not writing a book
during the game you're trying to score
points so 95 has no ac no benefits other
than looking kind of
cool rad because you're oh i'm leaving
the bishop hanging i'm so cool but the
reality is after bishop b3
um it bites you in the in the you know
where because now the bishop has no
escape squares
so knight b6 actually allows you to go
down and accomplish another item on the
wish list because bishop b3 is forced
now go ahead and reap the benefits one
comment here why is knight takes e4
bad because some people with a sharp
tactical i might notice that this move
seems to win a pawn
and it does but it's still bad
it's so bad it's still bad why is it bad
it just feels very very unsafe yeah
exactly it and it is uh but you have to
find sort of the concrete manifestation
of
of why why that is thank you so much
nicola
thank you um
okay wait okay so i mean obviously
knight takes e4 is going to win the
night
but then you've got bishop takes f5 and
then you've got knight f6
oh that's exactly right that's exactly
and people might look at this and say
wait a minute but
this doesn't win anything why is this
good but just look at the position for a
second everything is just the
pawn structure is weak black's whole
position here is collapsing there's a
million threads and you found that ins i
like your instincts there
so it's not only about it's not always
about winning material sometimes the
position can just be overwhelming so
let's say i go queen e5 just to test
your
your tactical sharpness but how do you
actually finish black off in a position
like this
um you go
bishop takes f7 oh i didn't even see
that about
well i don't know if it works i just
said do it do it let's see it
you can play it on the board let's see
if it's okay i think it it just might
oh i think it doesn't just check me oh i
gotta go here right if i go
bishop h6 is mate so oh my god but
man this is scary for black so i
actually i mean i just like moved my
my bishop out um yeah i like to e3 then
you go rookie one
yeah that's what i was thinking i think
from a human perspective it's just
but black is busted i don't see anybody
would be able to defend this
um but if you were like
as i like to say an old russian not all
russian
if you're an old russian you would pay
attention to this bishop on h2
the queen has cut off its retreat square
so if you can move your queen away with
tempo
for certain way of cutting off the
bishop and how exactly g3 or even
more with tempo what other moves oh f4
either actually works i think g3 works
as well nothing wrong with that
but f4 wins the game immediately because
yeah you just take off take the bishop
yeah or i'm gonna i'd probably play like
bishop takes f7 because that's the first
thing
no but that's actually a very nice move
and i think it has great amount of
practical value
it has a great amount of practical value
so in any case
um that is why knight takes e4 doesn't
work and you take the bishop on the nine
on f5
and in this position you've accomplished
sort of the top item on your wish list
but there's one more item
that you can accomplish here and i'd
like you to try to tell me what that is
and with what
move you can accomplish it
okay wait that involves me actually
deciding what else i want yeah exactly
it involves you trying to find the next
move
um okay so what else do i want to do
here i've
got my i've gotten the night nitrated
i've
i've gotten like a little bit more space
now
it's feeling okay here um
i think i probably just want to play
something like
i mean that bishop is still like on h2o
yeah that's something you should keep in
mind with your peripheral vision so it
would be great if you could
simultaneously solve the problem of that
bishop but also accomplish something
while you're at it
okay well this there's something there's
something is uh something that i need to
think about
exactly yeah take your time so what can
you accomplish with that bishop on h2 is
the key question here
okay this is this is where i actually
don't know um
okay so what are white's assets here
let's let's think about it from
white's perspective for a second what
assets does white have from a general
perspective
the pair of bishops yeah exactly so
could you get rid of that
yeah so i want to go bishop four exactly
that would be the right one right
so i i just wanted to play bishop f4 but
i didn't exactly like that that's it
yeah there's nothing i i i i maybe i
misled you a little bit yeah
okay nephes as well this seems familiar
yeah
um oh he just said he said yeah 2012.
wow that's awesome number eight years
ago
and he remembers the year um so bishop
f4 is the move
and and black went on to win the game
it's not that
overwhelming but it's very unpleasant
for white because of the pawn structure
um man i don't know how this nepo guy
became a gm i mean like clearly
like all he does is lose games man
that's like i mean i just want to say he
played some really really cool games
against geary um this tournament because
i was doing the casting
every single morning so uh levy and i
like really saw some beautiful games
yeah and he kept kicked by in blitz a
couple days ago consider that sort of
retroactive revenge
for me showing uh for me showing this
loss thank you pihar
for gifting to uh to yan um so anyways
uh now bishop e5 would be quite a bit
inferior because it would allow this
bishop to develop to g5
and sometimes you just got to think in
terms as simple as what are the assets
that my opponent has can i eliminate any
of those assets
here he has the bishop here can i
eliminate the bishop here yes and then
white is left with these weaknesses
these pawn weaknesses and that
he can't even compensate them with the
bishop bear and nepo says i remember i
didn't see bishop f4 india until it was
played yeah and sometimes you sort of
miss
you sort of miss these moves in the
course of your thought you think about
complicated things and then you miss
sort of the
the simple retreats um
so bishop f4 is is is is better for
black and so this kind of encapsulates
epitomizes the concept of a wish list
many many different types of positions
people are just very pessimistic in
general they're like i can't do this i
can get this done i can't get that done
i take the opposite stance and ask
myself what is the
best what is the equivalent of you know
finding a tesla on the street that's
unowns with its keys in the ignition oh
okay
i was trying to craft that in a way so
as not to suggest that i'm
that i'm stealing cars in my spare time
um and and and by asking yourself that
you are
opening your eyes to possibilities that
otherwise your
otherwise pessimistic brain would not
necessarily consider and i think
everyone tends to be a pessimist on the
chessboard
you have to artificially inflate
yourself with a little bit of optimism
that is true teslas have wireless keys i
can't even get that right
i can't get any analogies right my
analogies inevitably contain some sort
of mistake so
apologies for that hey unconventional
okay um
so those are a couple of concepts that i
wanted to lay out for you today
um so just to recap first we considered
sort of
purely positional solutions um and
there were a couple of things in that
regard that that you can take away
the first is obviously never to switch
off your tactical detector
um there are situations in which
you might classify the position in a
particular way and
that hurts you from looking for tactics
you shouldn't try to label positions as
tactical or positional
we're taught to do that by things like
puzzles uh which we kind of
label as tactics but real chess isn't
kind of like that remember that game
with knight c7 knight a6
the line between positional thinking and
tactics was blurred
number two um the concept of
inaccessibility and making concessions
don't be afraid to do things like weaken
a square or
i don't know put a piece on a bad square
temporarily if you are achieving other
aims
sometimes that is necessary yes um
and a couple of other things we talked
about that you can sort of internalize
uh on your own time as well yeah i'll
definitely be reviewing the vlog